we talk about the economy like it's some
kind of science I mean I have a degree
in economics a social science we look at
graphs we do calculus and we feel like
we're scientists and in a big sense we
are but what this graph hides is that
what we're dealing with here are people
people who make decisions based on how
they feel and that's really hard to
predict and control we do it see the
inflation video for how the FED is like
a puppet master we do it but it's really
hard to control and predict so a
recession is almost certainly coming you
may be watching this in like nine months
and the recession is here I don't know
the fact is by looking at this line what
we can say is that a recession is
natural and normal it is a part of our
modern economic system it will likely
come and then go people will lose jobs
businesses will close and at some point
for a million tiny little reasons things
like policy and just general feelings in
a bunch of people's guts this graph will
stop going down and it will start going
up again